hi my name is Samuel Leeds and I am here
with mr. sad Hussein thank you much
salmon how's it going buddy sorry saying
is in the building and I've been trying
to get him in our offices for how many
months now a good few months we've been
trying a good few months he's finally
here and he's gonna absolutely blow your
way with content around joint venture
Inc yeah using other people's money
leveraging kind of achieving more
getting there getting there quicker yeah
yeah and utilizing other people's time
money expertise you can get you can
really fast-track your way to success
absolutely so why don't you start search
because we're friends we've been friends
now for a long time yes and you live
close by to me but why don't you stop by
kicking off just hurts a little bit
about what you do and your background so
my focus generally tends to be on
finding what I call very good
opportunities and partnering people have
got the money and sharing the profit so
it started off really with being in a
place where I wanted to get into
property but just didn't have the money
or the knowledge started to getting a
bit of knowledge but actually having a
bit of cash helps as well yes
or somebody's cash at least and I just
really stumbled into a deal where it was
a deal I was sourcing so that's when I
started outsourcing deals initially and
I was going to sell that on to somebody
and the person whose property was the
vendor he was about to get repossessed
he was going to lose the property we'd
struck a deal the person I was gonna
sell it on to and he was a little bit
unsure about the numbers and I was
thinking if this doesn't happen
the sellers gonna lose his has the
buyers gonna lose out on what I think is
a reasonable deal I'm not gonna earn a
fee and I've done all the work yeah
so in the end we agreed with the buyer
look don't charge I want to charge you a
fee you don't need to pay a fee I'll do
the work I'll get up running show you
you'll learn the rent a quickly thought
you're gonna earn out of it and that's
really how I just stumbled into my first
joint venture yeah there's a number of
years ago now and that would earn me
about 47 pounds or something a month on
Godwin okay which we still high-speed
gym membership it's something but very
quickly realise actually I'm gonna need
a lot of these before you know I can say
I'm I'm okay and and then I started
looking at a bigger projects and and
got more into HMOs so really HR moles
professional nets in Birmingham has what
I've been doing for a good number of
years now and I tend to do big
renovations on those create really nice
environments and using other people's
money they fund them we get them up and
running we do a profit share room and
that really tends to be what I focus on
and more recently being looking at some
bigger projects and developments as well
super exciting and your strategy is so
good because I mean HMOs a great yeah
and I know you invest quite a lot of
money on the refurb but you don't leave
it all in there do you know so we look
at financing strategies at the at the at
the back end to get most of that money
back out yes so the investors pretty
much got more so money back out they've
got a little bit of money left in
they've got a really good return on that
capital that yeah in the property and
we've got properties that are almost
brand new houses ones are finished and
it's funny actually cuz I know we've
spoke because we both teach property as
well don't worry certainly to it to an
extent and buying a property renovating
it and pulling the money out it's a
really difficult one to teach isn't it
because you can't guarantee exactly how
it's gonna go absolutely because there's
so many variables it you just can't
control yeah but there are a number of
things that you can and those ones you
focus on making sure you you do the
property to a good standard variation or
it's gonna let well there's somewhere
where there's some good capital growth
potential in the future yeah so you know
these kind of things you can control
exactly working on that I think it's the
importance oh great but it's a difficult
one to sort of give a case today at the
crash course and just say this is how I
did it go and do it and there's people
that do do that there's people that make
it look so easy
yes and it just isn't it's dead there's
a lot involved some people gloss over it
yeah you know you buy a house you spend
some money on it you refinance he get
all the money back and you get off on
today exactly and it was probably easier
to do that in 2008 2009 yeah but but it
is still possible and I've done that and
I'm doing that you are so tell us in
regards to joint venture so you learned
the skills first what would you say the
number one step is to being successful
in property and I think having a clear
purpose in terms of what it is that
you're trying to achieve
yeah it's really important which is what
you needed to begin with and you learned
about property and you had clear purpose
but then you
oh jeez I mean I don't know if you can
relate to this because I've got a
sourcing company I know you've sourced
properties but sometimes it's so painful
that in the property go isn't it
you know you find this deal and you know
you're gonna get paid like two or three
grand or whatever it might be but
passing that deal on someone else and
know that they're gonna become
financially free from it and you're
gonna make a few thousand pounds it's
quite painful definitely but you can't
buy everything no you can't sometimes
its there's lots of good deals out there
that you think well you know I'm taking
this one for myself and I've got these
other two what do we do with these yes
or cinimon you learning a fee you know
you're able to kind of read best in the
business in marketing you continue to do
more you're helping people that want to
sell you're helping investors I want to
get on the ladder on fire yeah so he's a
win-win but yeah right it's painful
sometimes you're potentially given a
huge amount of yeah profit to somebody
else what is that like for the benefit
of a but what your same size which is so
cool is you're saying okay first step
get focused learn strategy brilliant so
let's say you're a deal sourcing machine
you know all about how to find good HMO
properties for instance but then rather
than having to use your own money you
can either want source it and pass it on
yeah and then you can save that money up
and invest that to buy it yourself or
three which is really interesting joint
venture now what advantage would you say
there is to joint venturing rather than
raising the finance or just passing it
on for a fee I think they the real
benefit from my perspective in terms of
joint venturing is that you're
leveraging something from somebody else
so they're bringing something to the
part you're bringing something
ultimately you're bringing is time
probably some skills some experience and
the project yeah and what they're
bringing you know what you're looking
for them to bring in these examples is
they bring the funds yes when you've got
a project like that
you're not restrict on how many dollars
you can do yeah you can just keep going
yeah if you've got an investor's giving
you a hundred thousand pounds you're
putting say twenty five thousand pound
deposit so that's for housing then
you've run out of money again yeah but
this way you can just keep going as long
as you're producing the result it's
working well there's no shortage of
people that you can find that will want
to work with you if you've got a track
record of making money
that's brilliant love that so is this
something you've been in a while to
adventuring yeah so I've been in
property
this is my 11th year coming up to 12
years now so you started around about
2006 yeah just when the market crashed
and everybody was running away and I
thought good time to run or not time to
get from being honest first two years
was a real struggle yeah really hard
work and I wasn't really getting any
results I was just trying everything
yeah just not getting anywhere but then
you know that the shift really came when
I found somebody experienced who knew
what they were doing who literally took
me under their wing and kind of guidance
cries and being a you know environment
where you've got the support and you've
got somebody who's done what you want to
do yeah and I think a lot of it was a
confidence he gave me the confidence and
I actually I can do this yeah rather
than being out on your own not too sure
it's terrible you know background is an
IT and I ran an IT company for 15 years
and one thing we did was kept our
knowledge on our cards close to our
chest share information because that's
really what you're getting paid for
that's how you earning money out in a
nightie and that's certainly what it was
for us then actually when you come into
property people are so open and so
helpful and supportive of each other and
that was a complete culture shock for me
first of all it is either in of myself
when I first started learning about
property when I was really young I was
even like this with my knowledge yes but
if you hold anything tightly you're not
then open to receive more absolutely so
the more you give the more you receive
more your grow as well yeah and you're
at you're a person of faith as well I am
yes and you know I'm a big believer that
you know we're put on this earth for a
reason and you know we need to we need
to lead a good life yeah is that like
well I love how generous you are with
your knowledge and it's great that you
even here today so so okay and you've
got so much background in probability
you're just so rich with with property
you've had a letting agent yeah so I I
think the experience really came when I
started learning about property I I just
went on this Drive about learning so I
felt like actually if I know how to do
this thing that'll be the answer to
everything and all sorted and I was just
obsessed about learning things and
trying this and trying that what wasn't
really getting a lot of results but what
I did do and I didn't realize then
looking back now
is it gave me a huge amount of
experience of doing different things
structuring deals in different ways yes
you know creative transactions you know
delayed payments lease options you know
flipping stuff and I kind of went
through a process I was doing lots of
different things but my core skills are
really being built of a sourcing
and then flipping and HMOs and
developments and all of yeah so when you
started in property then around about
2006
you said the first couple years was a
real struggle yeah learning Lots yeah
but a struggle when did you really have
that breakthrough with results the
breakthrough came a couple of years
later when I just felt like I was doing
the right things but just not getting
the right result yes I thought I'm doing
what it's supposed to do I'm telling I'm
telling the seller that you know I'll
take your mortgage on and you can go one
and we'll be sorted and you know I'll
give you a pound for it and that's what
they told me to do yeah but it just
wasn't quite working and realizing
actually it's it's it's more about
people understanding people it's about
the relationships and I think that when
the the biggest support and the biggest
gain I got from my mentor the shortest
period of time at that and that moment
was the understanding this is about
people yeah the people business so
whether we working with sellers and
we're helping them or whether work
working investors equally there are
challenges that they have and we're
trying to help them so a seller might be
in a situation where they need to move
on with their life and you're finding a
solution around their property and
invest if they've got 100 thousand
pounds sitting in the bank and reality
is it's a problem because it is winning
in value they put it somewhere they need
somewhere where it's gonna be safe it's
gonna give them a return
ultimates all about people and
relationships yeah that that was the the
lightbulb moment for me that's great and
then you started doing deals yeah - tell
me then I mean I don't know I don't know
how specific you can you can be on a
public channel like this but what would
a typical case study of a joint venture
perhaps look like with you so I mean
typically I tend to buy properties in
Birmingham prices been increased in the
last couple of years yeah big time you
saw a cookie cutter approach for a long
time I said I talk about things in that
way because I never take the credibility
of everything it's always other people
around me and work with me that that
help make everything happen yeah so the
cookie cutter approach we use for a long
time was a we buying at about one
hundred and forty thousand pounds for a
property we spend about 60 yard thousand
pounds on it so you up to about two
hundred thousand pounds and then we'd
refinance to 60 to 70 on a commercial
valuation so with pretty much got the
p'tee put put with six on sweets in
every in to enter into every house a
major innovation and what that also
means it runs smoothly than afterwards
is there's very little in terms of
maintenance cost going forward but then
there's enough there for us to be able
to refinance and take most of money yeah
about 75% not really and it varies
massively with the lenders in terms of
their criteria of core and it allowed
you to take and your history experience
all these things have a factor because I
work with lots of other people sometimes
a property might be saying the Vestas
name and you know I'm sitting the
background is getting it all done and
we've got an arrangement in terms of how
we can have a profit share and on that
basis when they're mortgaging it's
looking at that individual as well as
their history so there are lots of lots
of variables but it's doable but it's
it's not scientific yeah Hart said I'll
do this this and this and it's gonna
produce this result everything sure
would you say that every deal was
different on a case by case basis like
it was is the joint venture partnership
different well they they can be but I
tend to take a fairly simple approach to
these things and the way I tend to do is
I ask the investor to to bring all the
cash for the project yeah and I'll
pretty much do everything else and we'll
share the the the net rental profit we
create each month yeah on a 50 basis
yep and any equity that we create in the
property that'll be on 50% each as well
so it's very cool straight but the money
that they put in is their money that's
their money so for example at let's say
it was let's say it was a two hundred
thousand pound into that project we just
gave it yeah sample of and we've created
say 60 grand of equity in it that's 30
grand each for your equity that 200
grand that was in there that still
theirs sure got yeah that's quite cool
yeah it's very simple sort of you know
it's you know if my world wide then six
year old if she didn't quite understand
it then there was something wrong so if
I could explain over there then it's
great so so you do all the work yeah
they put in all the money and you go
fifty percent profit share on any of the
profits yeah and all the property crazy
that's great yeah so just just a
clarification on that which I think is
really important sometimes there's some
misconceptions about how joint ventures
work for me joint venture is ultimately
about showing the risk and the reward
yes so we're talking about everything's
kind of going
tastic the reality is sometimes project
costs more they take longer you know
that happens in property so the investor
takes to the good with a bad the benefit
is because the experience and track
record we mitigate a lot of those risks
but a joint venture really is about
sharing the risk and the reward yeah so
it can go wrong and it can go right the
alternative of course is you borrow
funds and structure that as a loan
arrangement yeah that way you'll have a
fixed amount and when you're borrowing
for an investor fixed period of time
fixed return regardless where it's gonna
cost more yeah raising finance what
would you say is more put your preferred
option joint venture or raising final
attented a mixture of both to be honest
it depends on the deal each as you said
each project is different yeah and
sometimes it might be you have the
project you look at what's viable and
I'm just on the phone here on the way
here actually are just speaking about a
we just trying to structure a deal and
once we've got that right then I will
look at okay what's what's the way we
can fund this yeah have I spoken to
recently that was interesting and
getting involved in some lines yeah
could we structure it is a loan to
delivery of this return could read it as
a joint venture that deliver this and
there might be two different
conversations I have with two different
people depend on who's gonna funding it
got yeah and we've returned do you ever
just borrow money for like five years
five years a lot of the the the loans I
tend to have in our business for our
project end to be a year at a time
that's enough time for me to have it in
a project recycle it what kind of return
on investment would you give to somebody
it varies massively it really does
depend on the on the project yeah yeah
so it's very difficult to kind of a to
pin that down to a number say generally
this because it will really depend on on
the project the timeframe the risk
associated got yes well now there's two
types of people that could be watching
this now one type of person could be
thinking or I would love to just give
somebody my money and have them do all
the work and give me a profit share or a
fixed return on investment the other
type of person is going to be people
that thinking I haven't got any money
but I sure I've got the knowledge or I
can get the knowledge and I wish that I
could have people giving me their money
to invest for them I'd be happy to pay
them a promise share or a fixed amount
those are the two types of people that
should be watching this video so my
question to you is sad my first question
is if you're the
kind of person that's thinking I've got
money and I'd love to invest it with
somebody and let them do all the work
watch what kind of a person should they
be looking for how do they know that
they're gonna find the right investor
and what kind of agreements should they
were looking for how do they pick the
right investor so the right the right
person to invest them I know the mantra
that I tend to follow is that you've got
to work with people that and get to know
you like you and trust you yep and if
you're you see I can have a glass water
here and say that's worth 100 pounds and
Asami I'll tell you that for 75 quid and
you'll look at that and say that's worth
100 pounds if I get a cent five quid I
can move you straight on 485 grab about
ten pound straight profit yeah that's
purely transactional there's no
relationship there we're just looking at
the commodity we know what the figures
are we just do that it would also be a
big con because it's not worth a hundred
pounds yeah but on the other hand yeah
you know we could look at this so what
if we were to do this and set this up in
a way where we can both work together
long term I can go off and invest in
plants and equipment as can supply do to
regularly you've got people are gonna
buy this from you frequently and then we
build it up as a relook at is it gonna
be a long-term relationship that we both
can benefit from a lot more and if we
were doing that we'd think about
actually you know how are we gonna get
on you know what what what's that
communication going to be like what how
are we you know 9 o'clock at night for a
conversation how are we at 8 in the
morning for speaking to each other
yeah because really you're almost
becoming business partners in that
situation yeah how does that
relationship gonna work now from if I'm
borrowing money from short period of
time for somebody for three months fixed
time fixed return then that's almost
transactional if I'm setting up a joint
venture partnership with somebody
setting up a HMI it's going to run on a
10-year joint venture arrangement that's
a completely different relationship yeah
so the type of people you look to work
with can depend on how much you're
looking for how long that money's going
to be for and how yeah what type of
relationship but ultimately why would
you work with people that you don't like
you don't know or you don't trust yeah
that's true although I guess the flip
side to that is if you were if you were
giving money to a
called borrowing money from the bank
you'd have any relationship with uh
purely transactional yeah which is which
was your example with the water so if
it's purely transactional and you know
that it's secure and safe then it
doesn't really matter it's less about
the the it's just purely about numbers n
of them but if it's if it's
joint-venture long-term then it's about
do you know them do you like Beatrice
bubble yeah yeah okay how would you find
somebody I mean if somebody say someone
who's listening has got a quarter of a
million in the bank and it's shrinking
in the bank and it's giving them no
interest how would they even go about
finding somebody that would be able to
safely invest them away so if you've got
funds and you're looking for some way to
work with really the key thing you you
mentioned there is it needs to be safe
yeah and that safety is going to come
from risk mitigation of risk mitigation
is going to come from working somebody
who's got the experience and track
record yeah see sometimes that's really
doing it well doing it well you know in
the locality or whatever it might be
yeah I know where you want to where you
want to work and if you're working with
somebody who's offering a phenomenal
return on that money they're involved in
a project that actually they've not done
before it's a first time it's
speculative
yeah there's no certainty there that
might happen yeah I get wiped out as
well cause there's a lot of photons next
question then is if you have the
knowledge let's say you've been on some
really good training programs you've
maybe bought one house you did it really
well but you're out of money and you're
wanting to borrow money from somebody
how do you get so many people because
you've done a lot of deals right yes how
do you find people to invest with you so
I think there's two things firstly
people need to know what you do yeah to
get at them yeah see you doing that I
need to talk to people and I think that
for me that one the best place has
always been networking events as you
know I've run networking events for
years yeah and you know I did go to some
business events initially and then I'd I
talked about investing in property but
then I realized I have to first sell the
concept of investing in property before
we talk about the imputation investing
in the property yeah if I'm at a
networking event I mean a property
networking event I'm with a room full of
people that already understand the
benefits of investing in property now
you just talk about the conversations
about what they're looking for
gosh yeah 13 so Mike
focus always tends to be how can I help
this person what they're looking for
yeah if they're asking me about what I'm
doing nicely some synergy I might talk
about it but I never go in say this is
what I'm pitching for this is what I'm
looking for with yes I see how I can
help somebody else love it the other the
other part really is social medias all
powerful these days yes and just get
your message out there and share with
people what you what you're doing which
is exactly what we're doing here yeah
that's how people get to know what
you're doing and whether you're just
starting out you're brand new done
nothing at all
but you know dereyes that blog that vlog
that people get to see what you're doing
people start those conversations I let
the world know that your investor get
really good at investing yes and go
networking but don't spam Facebook
groups nah yeah I had someone literally
just phone up this morning and spoke to
my PA said can I please be riad Adhan to
the UK Facebook group I've been blocked
for spamming but now that's awesome so
what did you what do you wanting to
achieve of the next 12 months and what's
your vision and goals so really we're
doing more of the same so a lot more
continue to HMOs yeah good quality hey
Jamal's in key locations no real change
there so we're going to carry on doing
that and then I'm looking at
developments as well so I've got one
large development boom can be doing a
moment I'm looking at a couple of others
mostly the conversions to apartments or
building a park that's great that's
really where the focus focus is now
amazing and it's a real pleasure to know
you and be able to talk business with
you and bounce ideas around if someone
wanted to get in touch with you what
would be the best way to be done you've
got a website would that be the best
best way to contact me social media or
my websites
yeah the same Doc's it's sad has saying
calm his name calm so it's been a real
pleasure thank you ever so much for come
on the show you look forward to hanging
out we said cheers so much thank you so
much for watching if you benefited from
that video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time